Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new Batman video Matt Reeves
did an interview recently talking about
the characters what's going on with his
movie explaining some of this story we
even got our first look at what the new
version of Arkham Asylum is going to
look like during the movie in Warner
Brothers just changed the release dates
of a bunch of their DC movies so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do with the Batman
sequels on the video so starting with
the big stuff first number five all the
release date changes the Batman movie
was only able to film about half of the
movie before the virus shut everyone
down all over the world we're all living
the Quarantine life right now originally
the movie was coming out June next year
in 2021 now the delay has gotten so big
they've been away from the set for so
long that they've had delay the movie to
October first weirdly enough though even
though everything's been delayed now not
every DC movie has been delayed the same
thing just happened to Marvel though
where you have a bunch of shifting movie
dates everything kind of moves down the
line a little bit so DC had a version of
that just happened to for them the new
order for all the DC movies that are
coming up goes like this it's Wonder
Woman 1984 coming out in August this
year The Suicide Squad movie is still
coming out August next year in 2021
James Gunn said that there haven't been
any big delays there in post-production
right now they finished filming the
movie a while ago Batman like I said is
coming out October 1st next year they
wanted to delay it to October because
they feel like they can make more money
in October and that's also the same week
where they released Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker movie which did gangbusters so
they're also kind of referencing that
hoping that it will also find the same
success that the Joker movie did and if
it wasn't clear there's not supposed to
be any kind of connection between
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie and Robert
Pattinson --zz Batman movie like the
Batman at the end of the Joker movie
isn't supposed to be Robert Pattinson
'he's batman both the directors todd
phillips and Matt Reeves said that their
movies aren't intended to crossover in
any way so if they do more with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker movies those will be its
own separate thing often that DC black
label of movies in the
Batman movies with Robert Pattinson are
setting up their own new continuity
those aren't intended to be prequels to
Ben Affleck's Batman or connected to
Wonder Woman Aquaman 2 or any of the
other Justice League movies some of the
DC movies will be connected going
forward some of them will not so I'll
just explain on a movie by movie basis
depending on what I'm doing videos for
so for all the other upcoming DC movies
they finally gave an update on the flash
movie that's coming out July 2022 now
it's only delayed a month but if you
wondered if they were making it they are
still making it we already know that
it's going to be a slightly different
version of flashpoint Ben Affleck's
Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman aren't
supposed to cross over as far as I know
maybe a cameo from cyborg or one of the
other Justice League characters but it
would be waist smaller than comic book
flashpoint there's a very good animated
flashpoint movie if you want to see more
comic book accurate flashpoint I don't
do this to me I don't know about the
what okay the Black Adam movie is still
coming out December 2021 that has not
been delayed yet The Rock keeps talking
about it on all his Instagram posts they
said that they're going to start filming
later this year that might be delayed
just a little bit but it sounds like
they'll still be able to hit their
release date Shazam - with the Shazam
Lee did just get delayed from April 2022
to November 2022 so it's coming out
about a year after the Black Adam movie
the weird thing about the Shazam movies
is that the kids are growing up so fast
that the more they delay it the older
the kids look so it becomes kind of
awkward by the time they get to the
third movie
I think they delayed the movie so much
just because there are so many different
actors schedules that they had to juggle
for that and you also have to consider
them trying to get the rock in for a
cameo by the end of the movie and he's
probably one of the busiest people in
Hollywood so it's a bit of a nightmare
to schedule a movie that big I'll
explain more about what's going on with
Shazam - the next time I do a Black Adam
video because we actually just did find
out what's going on with the story of
the Black Adam movie they haven't bumped
Aquaman to yet that's still coming out
Christmas week December 2022 but they
might wind up bumping it because that's
only a month after Shazam - three
talking more about the Batman movies you
may have seen Matt Reeves did a huge
interview just a little while ago
explaining the origin of his Batman
movies how they're different and style
and tone from all the other Batman
that have come before how his characters
are different I'll just read his quote
here so he references his Planet of the
Apes movie during this interview when
he's talking about the Batman movie he
says the way I love Apes is the way I
loved Batman actually the only two
franchises that might have been
something that I would have been
connected with amazingly are the ones
that I was approached by meaning that
Warner Brothers approached him about
doing the Batman movie not the other way
around he talks about having a really
deep connection to the story that they
wrote for this new Batman movie and then
talks about his love for the other
Batman movies he's a big fan of Tim
Burton's Michael Keaton Batman movies
and everyone's a fan of Christopher
Nolan's Batman movies but he's also a
big fan of Batman the Animated Series
big shout out for Kevin Conroy one of
the best Batman of all time just happens
to be animated he then goes on to say
that when he was pitching his version of
the Batman movie to Warner Brothers he
said that he wanted to do something
different a humanist Batman movie the
same thing that he did for his Apes
movies he went on to say that Warner
Brothers was pretty much on board with
his pitch and his take on the character
they didn't make him change any really
big things about the movie the reason
why they went with Robert Pattinson
instead of doing the movie with Ben
Affleck is because when Matt Reeves came
onto the project they did a complete
rewrite of Geoff Johns and Ben Affleck's
original Batman scripts it became a
totally different movie but that was
because they didn't go to Matt Reeves to
ask him to do the Batman movie until
after Ben Affleck had completely left
the character and the movie the main
reason he said he went with a younger
version of Batman is because he said
this Batman is still figuring things out
he's only been Batman for a couple of
years he's supposed to be struggling
with the weight of his mission and the
overall decay in Gotham just beating
down on him literally and metaphorically
so too when he says he's trying to make
a humanist Batman movie that just means
giving the villains as much character
development arcs as the Batman character
a really good example of this is the
Edward Nash tin version of the Riddler
that they're doing there was a scene
that they were filming earlier that
leaked a while ago before they had to
shut down the movie where the police had
found one of the Riddler's latest
victims it was a man tied up and
blindfolded in a chair with a sign hung
over him with the Riddler's trademark
question mark in a message written in
blood saying no more lies the lies that
the Riddler was referring to were the
hypocrisy of the
state of the Gotham City Police
Department in the court system Peter
Sarsgaard is playing the current
district attorney in Gotham during the
movie his name is Gill Colson he's not a
comic book character but you'll
understand why in a second he said that
his character is supposed to be super
rotten and will lie falsify evidence in
order to convict criminals so we just
paints the Riddler and some of the other
Batman villains in the movie like the
penguin and all the other potential
rumored villains in a more sympathetic
light the movies largely inspired by the
long Halloween enduring the story of
that comic book Batman goes around
trying to find the identity of this
killer who's going around killing all
these mobsters before they find out
what's really going on all the usual
suspects get rounded up by Batman he
goes to the Riddler he goes to the Joker
he goes to the penguin to find out as a
did it turns out they did not do it in
the real killer is someone else so it
sounds like there's a little bit of that
going on inside Gotham City during the
movie where you have the district
attorney who's kind of rotten trying to
throw criminals in prison for crimes
they didn't commit so it sounds like the
Riddler is trying to get rid of this
rotten district attorney during the
movie and it gives him a more realistic
character arc than what you saw from say
Jim Carrey's Riddler even though I'm a
huge Jim Carrey fan but by the time they
got to the schumacher Batman movies
stylistically they got so Baroque and
over stylized that it became way more
high fantasy in way less grounded it is
fun to go back every once in a while and
watch him go fool Jim Carrey as the
Riddler though just in terms of tone and
style and look it sounds like based on
what Matt Reeves is saying and what
we've seen from the Gotham City sets
that they filmed on that the new Batman
movie looks somewhere between
Christopher Nolan's very real world
Gotham in some of the Gothic
architecture of Tim Burton's Batman
movies before the Schumacher movies
turned that up to 11 the number one
because the district attorney Gil
Coulson in this first movie seems like a
pretty big character it sounds like
they're not planning on doing Harvey
Dent or a two-face origin story until
the second Batman movie like I said
we've talked about how this Batman movie
is inspired largely by the long
Halloween comic book story the long
Halloween is where Harvey Dent becomes
two-face infamously getting the acid
thrown in his face then resurfacing
months later in the story as to
face but he's already the district
attorney when that story picks up
there's no other big character that
introduces him so the only reason they
would do this in the movie with this
different guilt Colson district attorney
is to number one give the villains like
the Riddler more of an origin story and
to give the sequel somewhere to go so
you do two phases a big character in the
Batman 2 or whatever they're going to
call that movie and if rumors are to be
believed they would introduce their new
version of the Joker during the third
movie of this new trilogy and it would
not be Joaquin Phoenix's Joker but that
wouldn't happen for at least five or six
years so I wouldn't worry about that too
much right now but obviously they will
probably do a new version of the Joker
at some point during this new trilogy we
still haven't seen an official look at
the cat woman's new costume although we
have seen her on set riding motorcycles
with Batman and we still have not seen
an official look at Colin Farrell's
penguin yet although there's been a lot
of really good fan art but everyone
posts all your predictions for this new
Batman movie in the comments below and
if you didn't see there is a brand new
Justice League dark HBO series that
they're going to be making live-action
if that wasn't clear people were
confused if it was live-action or
animated it will be a live-action I just
did a teaser video for that you can
click here to watch that and click here
for my brand new venom 2 spider-man
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!